I don't know if they were fully prepared
for what they call when I logged on
Karen Gillen sharing the backstory to
this hilarious moment on the gram when
she had couples therapy and full nebula
makeup I was late to the session and I
had worn them oh I'm late because I'm at
work so they had an inkling but I don't
think they realized it was going to be a
full makeup and then and then yeah it
was um the therapist couldn't stop
laughing actually
I felt bad for her yeah Karen's marble
co-stars found it pretty funny too Chris
Pratt this is the best and Zoe Saldana
declares this needs to be in a movie
oh please he left out some important
information but
that is the gist of it well the
Guardians of the Galaxy needed a good
laugh volume 3 out Friday is the cast
final chapter in the MCU
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends uh I'm gonna
miss the people so much like we I know
that everyone says oh we're a family but
on a film set but we like genuinely are
we've been doing this for almost a
decade
um and we all know each other really
well like you know
poem was a bridesmaid at my wedding like
we're close
um so I'm just gonna miss all the
moments in between scenes where we're
laughing telling stories and all that
stuff my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
and want to make things perfect
just hated things the way they are it's
a rocket origin story so you're going to
learn a lot about the character's
backstory and that's quite sad actually
but then it's cut through with all of
these the Guardians humor that we know
and love and everyone's being ridiculous
and bickering in a really funny way but
also the stakes are really high and it's
really emotional and we have to save our
friend and also it's the Final Chapter
so that's why it's emotional as well of
course the movie's dropping on the same
weekend as another big debut oh the
coordination I'm definitely going to
find a British pub in New York and go
down and watch it go hold on hold on to
the Heritage all that even though I'm
Scottish but I don't know for part of
the UK and it feels like a British thing
to do so I'm gonna do it
meanwhile Karen's making history of her
own and the superhero sequel it feels
like an incredible honor to be at the
receiving end personally of Marvel's
first album I didn't say it but it was
said at me
um which I've decided is cooler than
saying it whoever it was that you were
in love with it sounds more like her her
do not bring me into them
knock it off what
I've just never noticed how black your
eyes were they were replaced by my
father as a method of torture he he
picked a pretty set
[Music]